from timcats.com rumble acquires locals
in a bid to expand creator economy the
company wants to foster high quality
content by giving creators control of
their content and data
very interesting move for those that
don't know rumble is a very popular
video player it's alternative to youtube
essentially it's got a lot of
independent and and conservative voices
on it and it's considered kind of like
an alternative to youtube there's been
many rumble seems to be doing really
well and seems to have large coffers as
it were and locals is basically dave
rubin's answer to patreon
so now rumble has acquired locals i
don't know what this will mean for the
people of locals who have their accounts
there but wow
this uh this is a fast move we have a
quote actually
quote we felt there was an opportunity
to fairly serve everyone by providing
the same tools large creators have
without preferencing rumble told tim
cast via email based on the premise that
small creators like friends and family
were no longer being prioritized on
platforms like youtube privately owned
rumble launched in 2013. the company's
creators felt large platforms focus on
multi-channel networks large
corporations and brands
unlike other platforms creators using
locals own not only their own content
but also the community data the data can
be analyzed to better understand and
engage with the creator audience with
more insight into who they are reaching
creators can expand their work and
continue to generate revenue without
outside influence instead they'll use a
subscription model locals has built
this is particularly interesting ian
what do you think about that i think the
consolidation of corporate power is
often done with good intentions dave
rubin sold you out
he got a bunch of big big popular people
in there with and by using his personal
brand and his trust and then he sold you
out he made i don't know they haven't
released how much money he got paid to
sell you out but he is up
what do you mean by sell them i mean
that he just got paid a lot of money and
got an offer he couldn't refuse to give
now control of all these people trusted
dave they trusted you right and now now
they have no choice but to be owned
their data is now owned by rumble this
is what google bought youtube i remember
that happening in 2008.
well so they say specifically that uh
you own your community data that's what
they say i don't know anything about
this deal to be honest i think the
bigger issue i have with um look i think
you know i tweeted out congrats to him
for pulling it off i think it's
fantastic i think there's uh there's
some critiques we have i think it's good
that the independent uh tech environment
is growing larger and more powerful and
ultimately this will be good because
there needs to be market competition
against youtube and patreon and silicon
valley this is what we're seeing however
that being said
i don't like
any
of how the system is operating and it's
not anything personal with rumble uh we
use we use rumble we uh um i'm i think i
think locals is fantastic
but the whole time
the patreon fiasco happened this is
basically you know patreon bans carl
benjamin they banned lauren southern
first and they banned carl benjamin they
basically nuked people's income without
warning or notice
overnight one day you know carl wakes up
his accounts deleted all his money is
gone
so what what ends up happening is we see
alternatives emerge saying we're going
to create centralized subscription
models just like patreon but with our
own unique version of it
and it's the exact same problem
i'm not a fan of it michael malus dave
sold you out dude
i hope that you got paid for this too
mike i hope that all the people on
locals got a percentage of this buyout
because it's your data that was sold
oh ian you get best this is why we're
building decentralized
technology where you can own your own
data and host your own stuff
i agree
i mean i've always been skeptical even
over the alternatives because there have
been alternative social media platforms
that came and went sold their viewers
deleted their content and then just
rebranded and started new again i'm like
wait wait hold on what about my old
content that i uploaded there like oh
it's gone i'm like
you know there's a lot of you know pump
and dump cryptocurrencies also out there
there's a lot of bad things that's why i
always prioritized building my own
platform my own email list that's why i
have lukencensor.com you have
timcast.com and i think this is the way
that it's going to go decentralized and
i think if you ever put your hope in a
centralized system or somebody else to
take care of something for you i think
there's a bigger chance you're always
going to be let down i want to put
subtech out of business
i want to put locals out of business i
want to put patreon out of business i
want to put all of these subscription
service services out of business
now that is just me being kind of
hyperbolic but the point i'm making is
you know for one ian spearheading with
with many other people the the on
foundations work which is creating
decentralized open source versions of
these tools which means
it's not just that you'll own your data
you'll own the domain you'll own the
server space it'll be yours and you can
set it up or you can join like a node
where someone's got centralized server
space and then you can you know
piggyback on it the issue i have here is
that the solution to the problems we
faced even by someone like dave rubin
has been to recreate the same system
which creates the same vulnerabilities
and the same problems
now i don't know if i would go as far as
you to say that they were sold out
because i don't know how this negatively
impacts someone like michael mouse yeah
me too i am open to following this i'm
really going to in the next coming weeks
because i want to know all the terms of
the contract that are going to be as
much as possibly publicly available
because maybe the people are going to
make out like bandits on this as well as
dave but dave i had a lot of faith in
you and i gave you the benefit of the
doubt i thought you were going to hold
on to locals for the next 20 or 30 years
and really do this at least try and do
it right
this is devastating to me so one thing i
think you can consider is um
and look look i know uh
dave i know the guys at rumble one thing
you consider you should consider is that
when you sign up for a service like
patreon subscribe star or
or locals
you're locked in
whether intentionally or not it's not so
much they own the data and they can
claim you own the data it's that
if you build up say 3 000 paying
subscribers on someone else's platform
and they're getting a cut of that you
can't leave they own you forever
now you can bag your your subscribers
and your followers guys i'm going to be
moving to a new platform please
subscribe there but i saw this i saw
what happened with patreon when patreon
nuked carl benjamin and all of his
people a bunch of his fans started
quitting and cancelling subscriptions
and hit everybody so i went from having
i think we had a few thousand people
donating
and then when everyone's like sorry tim
i can't support patreon i said i set up
subscribe star an alternate platform you
can subs you can support me there and
the attrition was massive people did not
move over so when i saw that i said
centralizing people's subscriber base
uh onto someone else's platform will
always be negative towards these
individuals and what we need is a
decentralized easy to install package
that someone can make their own version
at timcast.com the first thing we did
was we hired a guy to make a very simple
website cost us a decent amount of money
and then we started posting members only
content as if it was any other you know
private subscription service
the amount of money that we would have
spent if we went with any of these
platforms be it patreon local
subscribers or otherwise
it was
seventy percent higher i'll put it that
way
when i start when i saw how much they
charge people to use their platforms i
was just like they are
extracting value from people like locals
they're taking what like eight to twenty
percent of your
monthly
they take some percent of your monthly
income and now that's going to rumble
and if the value of that them taking a
large percent of the income is that the
network effect of locals so if you leave
locals you lose that network effect
one of the things i think you know
could be considered as well is that uh
rumble recently hired a bunch of video
creators and personalities to make
content for them i wonder who they're
going to sell their company too with the
with the acquisition of locals
theoretically the integration would
undercut any of their creators for
making similar similar deals now google
can buy rumble and now you're gonna make
out like a bandit chris pavlov pavlovsky
good job
i know chris i don't think this is
ultimately a bad thing i just don't like
the idea of centralizing people's
corporate consolidation is not
inherently bad it's just super dangerous
for liberty we use rumble i think
rubble's great yeah it's fast it's cheap
it's effective there's there's no
censorship my bigger concern is people's
income being centralized and then sold
around right so so here's what you got
to understand
uh and again with all due respect to
today i think i said congratulations i
think i think you know he did great work
and alternative media growing bigger and
more powerful is a good thing
my my answer is more like my view of
this is
you don't want to work for somebody and
it's already bad enough there's youtube
rules there's twitter rules whatever
making your own space where you can
control it is good
but if the idea of locals was that you
would control your own community but
that but that dave could then sell your
community to somebody else completely
undercuts
what i guess the the the story was
supposed to be
i don't want someone to be like hey
i'm running a service if you use it i
guarantee you x and then i'll say okay
great like you said oh dave's going to
own this forever i trust him
and then he sells it and now you don't
know who you're answering to now you
don't know what terms will change and
they could i don't like the idea that
your income your subscribers your fans
can be sold to someone else
i'm still waiting it's crazy i'm still
waiting for all the details to come out
of this um and they should be coming out
if they don't that's when people should
be worried but let's see exactly what
the deal was let's see what the
contracts are going to be let's see how
they're going to change let's see the
terms it's going to be interesting to
see how this went down i think it's a
good thing look i'm not trying to run on
the parade but i you know i think being
critical is fair because i've been
critical of the centralized subscription
services from the beginning regardless
of who owns it in a lot of ways google
buying youtube was fantastic for
creators because they created the
partner they were able to subsidize and
create the partner program and start
paying people youtube wasn't able to do
that when it was chad hurley but
the downside then is google's corporate
censorship model took over
the fear would be if you know rumble
sold which i don't think it will though
well no one ever thinks it's going to
happen that's true but it's totally
legally allowed to i did not think
locals would sell i did not yeah to
anybody and then they do
but
i'm not i'm not i'm not too worried
about this i i think ultimately look
rumble i think is fantastic and i think
them gaining more uh more power in the
space to help push back against the
censorship and the big tech
it's a good thing it's a good thing
um i'll just put it this way
i don't i've talked to people about
locals and i'm like i think it's
fantastic that dave was like patreon
censorious and bad so we need our own
space and he made it and other people
used it i just wish people like michael
miles for instance decided to write a
check for a grand to just make his own
version of it and not give away 10
percent of his revenue i just don't
understand this this is what this is
what drives me insane is that tulsi
gabbard michael malus you know who uh
other people who are using locals and
again no disrespect to locals but just
in terms of these people
you go online you say web dev they'll
say we can make you this exact thing for
a thousand bucks we'll have it done in
overnight finger snap
nah i just don't get it but i guess
people have said they want the network
that it's like you're on this platform
other people are on it
i just wish people were more
freedom oriented i guess and and and
took the took the responsibility upon
their shoulders and protected their
assets and had more control maybe that's
just me maybe i'm too uh arrogant and i
refuse to like give up
you know
anything that i'm doing to anybody else
for any reason hey i had i had my
subscription service for seven years
so i believe in that idea as well
decentralization is the idea that i
think we should be promoting but we
could promote it by giving by being
examples of it rather than just
following the herd and the flock i just
i i just don't understand it guys i'm
just going to say one more time
if
most of these services have a 10 feet
that means if you have 100 patrons
and they're each giving you 10 bucks
you're getting a thousand bucks a month
you're giving a hundred dollars per
month to that company
now that can make sense if you're not
not expecting to have a large following
but let's say you have
a thousand people giving you money now
you have you know ten bucks per person
you're getting ten thousand dollars
you're giving a thousand dollars per
month to these platforms for what for a
one-time fee of a thousand bucks a web
dev can make you a simplified version of
this that's why i'm like we need to make
free and open source software that we
can just give to people and they can get
their domain
12 bucks they can get some server space
50 bucks
spend a one-time rate if they've got you
know
i guess the problem is people are like
how do i get to the point where a
thousand bucks unless i use someone
else's infrastructure and i'm like
save up
uh save up money
do what you can because then you hire a
guy for for a thousand bucks and maybe
you can even get cheaper if you've got a
friend or you can learn how to do it
yourself it is it is plugins it is
wordpress it is plugins it is simplified
you can make it server space is
extremely expensive you know there's no
there's no perfect solution which is why
one hasn't been created yet but keep
know that if someone else has your data
they're gonna sell it and they may not
but
think like that the amount of money that
we would have given away timcast.com if
we went with any one of these platforms
i i it's
it is it is substantial we could have
started six companies with the money
we've saved
easily that's what's crazy to me i know
the cost of bandwidth i know the cost of
development and i i look and i'm just
like
how come we don't have someone going to
these these individuals like michael
mal's friends who are a huge fan of
being like hey michael here's a guy pay
him one time he'll make the site for you
and you don't have to give anyone money
ever again it's all yours don't give it
away i just don't understand that i just
don't get it but you know what look look
that's just me
you know i see something and i don't
understand why people are just giving
things away
instead of trying to to build up
something that is secure and unbannable
but hopefully i'll put it this way
before we go to super chats
what we're working on should should put
these companies out of business all of
them i don't care their political
ideology i'm not not necessarily because
some people won't want to buy a server
space and install a package
but we're going to make it so that
instead of having to worry about a
thousand bucks to hire the web dev
all that work's going to be done and
you're going to just click a link and
it's going to say drag and drop this
into your onto your into your server
file here's how you do it and then boom
you have a subscription service website
done and here's all the other people
using the service and then you can pick
who you want to see you can whitelist
and black list corporations it's going
to be great yeah it's all free free 100
and that means the only costs you'll
have is the credit card exchange rate
which server costs which can be insane
so that that's that's a big part of this
is server costs figuring out how to mesh
network servers but it will use a
library or have it local it'll always be
cheaper than what you'd give to a
private company that's seeking to profit
off of your subscriber base yes
and especially as it scales up they do a
lot of the work for you that's what
makes those companies look nice but
that's what we're doing we're doing the
work for you but we also do have
torrent based uh video hosting
and there are other platforms that can
do extremely low cost i mean
interestingly rumble is one of them and
do very low cost hosting and so at a
certain point
you don't need these services to
function like this
it's it's it's it's like wordpress
plugins man i'm not even kidding how
ridiculously easy it is to set up
you you get a wordpress you download
subscriber plug-in
double-click it and you're done we're
just simplifying it making it as easy as
possible like one click and the thing's
all set to go but it already is easy
that's just me man i don't know look i i
look at the culture war
i look at some of i look at so many of
these these uh personalities who are
making tons of money and i'm like
why don't they have 10 more shows the
young turks have a network where they've
got a dozen shows they make money and
they dish it out to all these people
then they get investors and they dish it
out to all these people they build more
shows they do more and i'm like why
aren't we doing that well we're doing
that quite literally with uh the tales
from the inverted world with the vlog
with several other shows that work on a
pop culture show we're working on and
then i just look at the right and the
moderates and the independence and i'm
like they don't do this they don't even
peter thiel right he goes after a gawker
he complains about fake news he funds
rumble that's fantastic but where's his
effort joe rogan complains about cnn
lying joe's massively wealthy he could
take a million bucks and be like have at
it
they just don't do it but you know what
whatever we'll do it and then we'll see
where everyone else ends up thanks for
checking out this segment from the tim
cast irl podcast if you want to watch
live you can check out this channel
monday through friday at 8 pm and don't
forget to smash that like button
subscribe to this channel and if you
want more unfiltered and uncensored
content with all of these guests go to
timcast.com and become a member all of
these guests you know and love in
exclusive segments on our website where
we are unrestricted in what we talk
about so you'll definitely not want to
miss it thanks for hanging out we'll see
you all next time